[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 hebdo sur tv 78 comme
chaque vendredi l'actualité du jour
l'essentiel de la semaine voici les
titres de ce 17 mai 2010 9 650 millions
de personnes dans le monde souffrent
d'obésité mot d'ordre pour les journées
européennes qui se tiennent actuellement
la maladie peut se guérir nous en
parlerons avec claudine canal présidente
de l'association allez quoi plus
jusqu'au scrutin du 26 mai nous
proposons de suivre la campagne
européenne dans les yvelines reportage
lors des meetings rencontre des
candidats aujourd'hui à nos trois
questions seront pour mathilde andraud
et 22e sur la liste du rassemblement
national et du côté de l'essentiel de la
semaine dans les yvelines françois
morton nouveau maire de guyancourt
sciences po saint germain qui lance un
diplôme sur le renseignement et paris
saclay met en avant ses innovations avec
l'événement et spring claudie de canal
bonjour et bienvenue en plateau
présidente de l'association elle les
poids plumes vous êtes aussi vite
vice-présidente pardon du collectif
national des associations d'obèses
aujourd'hui et demain samedi 18 mai ce
sont les journées européennes de
l'obésité avec un thème cette année
l'obésité est une maladie qui se soigne
pourquoi ce choix
déjà mais parce qu'en fait la population
n'est pas au courant c'est une journée
qui est destiné pour informer la
population que la maladie est tu
l'obésité pardon est une maladie et il
faut arrêter tous les dictats qu'on peut
recevoir en disant que c'est un état de
fait
oui aujourd'hui on considère encore
malgré l'évolution de la communication
autour du sujet que ce n'est pas une
maladie c'est la faute des personnes qui
sont obèses pour faire simple et ce qui
est encore plus grave c'est que même
dans le monde médical certaines
personnes disent que c'est pas une
maladie avec un effet néfaste on imagine
sur les malades en plus en plus mais sur
logiquement ils sont là ils sont
victimes de discriminations et ils vont
puisse faire soigner ses traits c'est
très grave
l'obésité est une maladie je vous
propose de regarder ce spot justement et
puis nous continuons la discussion juste
après je vous présente
amanda vous l'a rencontré pour la
première fois et vous pensez
probablement qu'elle mange beaucoup et
qu'elle fait peu de sport parce qu'elle
est obèse
la plupart des gens pensent que ceux qui
gèrent bien leurs équilibres
énergétiques restent minces
alors que ceux comme amanda qui mange
trop et ne font pas assez d'exercice
physique deviennent obèses
nous voyons l'obésité comme un choix de
vie et le traitement est simple manger
moins et faire du sport
cela paraît logique mais c'est faux que
se passe-t-il si amanda décide de perdre
du poids en se mettant au régime
après tout les gens atteints d'obésité
devrait manger moins voilà ce qu'il se
passe elle perd du poids mais ces
niveaux d'hormones change son cerveau
entend tout ça et commence à agir pour
rétablir le niveau de masse graisseuse
qu'elle a perdu elle a faim plus souvent
et sans le savoir elle brûle aussi moins
de calories qu'avant car le cerveau à sa
propre perception des calories dont le
corps a besoin
il n'y a pas qu'une seule cause qui
explique le taux d'obésité qui augmente
les changements des modes alimentaires
liées au contenu chimique et nutritifs
une activité physique moins fréquentes
des niveaux de stress plus élevé un
sommeil insuffisant et perturber jouent
tous un rôle et entraîne une prise de
poids
il est temps d'arrêter de dire à amanda
que c'est sa faute si elle est obèse
il est temps de reconnaître que
l'obésité est une maladie pas un choix
de vie et que ceux qui en souffrent
mérite d'être soignés et n'ont pas jugé
au premier regard il est temps d'agir
contre l'obésité
demain samedi 18 mai ce sont les
journées européennes de l'obésité nous
en parlons donc avec vous en france 15 3
% des adultes souffriraient de cette
maladie est ce que c'est un chiffre qui
doit inquiéter et puis surtout dans
quelle proportion ils évoluent alors il
évolue très vite et ça touche de plus en
plus en fait la soul et les enfants donc
c'est pour ça qu'on fait aussi séjourné
pour informer la population et c'est
très important que les gens prennent
confiance que c'est une maladie qu'il
faut qu on se soigne et qui a
différentes pistes pour se soigner et il
faut vraiment avoir affaire à des
professionnels de santé qui sont au
courant de cette maladie pour être
considéré comme obèse il ya liem c'est
celle indice de masse corporelle
notamment qui est un indicateur s'il
dépasse les 30
on est considéré comme obèse déjà il ya
un surpoids à partir de 25 et sa soeur
de 30 ccc l'obésité le calcul est plutôt
facile à faire vous trouverez les outils
sur internet
à quel moment on doit s'inquiéter à quel
moment il faut agir véritablement bas
quand on voit que notre prise de poids
elle est importante mais bon l'obésité
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
c'est une maladie qui peut effectivement
bain en gendre et diverses autres
maladies puisque c'est pas une maladie
orpheline malheureusement elle récupère
tout au passage et il faut s'inquiéter
ben quand on commence à peut-être
prendre du poids mais c'est peut-être un
indicateur mais c'est pas le seul je dis
bien l'obésité c'est beaucoup plus
multifactorielle il faut vraiment avoir
recours donc c'est le thème de cette
année c'est bon parcours de soins pas
aller voir des charlatans parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup qui moi j'aime bien cette
expression se faire du gras sur les gros
excusez moi mais je suis complètement ça
il faut vraiment s'orienter vers des
parcours bien ciblée est bien cadré et
et voir un psychologue parce que ça peut
venir aussi par rapport à un problème
psychologique du sommeil l'apnée du
sommeil l'hypertension il ya plein de
facteurs qui sont comme je vous disais
bon on récupère tout au passage donc le
visiter c'est une malade
qui récupère toutes les maladies
associées orpheline quoi voilà donc
c'est une maladie et ça se soigne
véritablement on peut se soigner et
quels sont les bons professionnels
avertis s'orienter quels sont les
parcours de santé même si j'imagine ses
propres chiffres aussi à chaque personne
alors il ya différentes choses il ya des
parcs ou médicaux donc on peut avoir
recours à ces parcours dans des soins de
suite de réhabilitation des jardins ce
matin aujourd'hui il y avait une journée
pour les adolescentes rebellyon il en a
tout autour de paris donc j'invite les
personnes bas nous contacter et on les
orientera parce qu'il ya aussi des
parcours pour les adultes
quels sont les professionnels à voir
c'est le diététicien déjà faire un bilan
nutritionnel pour savoir où on en est
des analyses biologiques voir un
nutritionniste voir un psychologue ou un
psychiatre ou un psychologue parce que
c'est une maladie qui peut résulter de
choc ou des choses comme ça il c'est
important et puis bien bien longtemps dû
revoir et de voir avec son généraliste
oui peut l'orienter
il n'y a pas que la prise en charge
chirurgicale a lancé ce n'est pas une
finalité
la chirurgie de l'obésité c'est vraiment
le dernier recours
ça s'adresse à des personnes qui ont
tenté plein de choses et qui ont eu des
régimes à rebonds et
et ça va pas et il y a aussi des
critères là on est au dessus des
critères annoncé tout à l'heure pour
avoir recours à la chirurgie il faut
avoir au moins un ami mca 35 avec les
maladies associées
mais c'est pas c'est pas une baguette
magique comme le dit notre affiche
justement il faut vraiment comprendre
conscience et être acteur aussi de sa
santé est pas le faire parce que c'est
l'esthétique c'est pas de l'esthétique
la chirurgie de l'obésité c'est vraiment
donc c'est quelque chose qui va vous
donner un coup de pouce mais ça va pas
tout faire si on n'associe pas tout ce
qu'on apprend en éducation thérapeutique
malheureusement ça ne marchera pas et
puis le regard des autres doit changer
aussi c'est l'objectif de ces journées
est il ya un mot qui vient d'apparaître
dans le dictionnaire c'est la
grossophobie est ce que pour vous c'est
un premier pas vers déjà une
reconnaissance de cette discrimination
aussi oui c'est déjà un pas donc c'est
madame bidart et me semble qu'ils
avaient évoqué le problème je crois que
c'était en décembre 2018 il me semble
bien
north 2010 est excusez moi je sais plus
bon tu apportes et grossophobie il faut
prendre conscience justement parce que
ben les personnes qui souffrent de
surcharge pondérale elles le vivent mal
et on les regarde alors déjà quand on
prend les transports en commun par
exemple
au regard de la tête aux pieds en disant
oh non il va pas s'asseoir à côté de moi
sera possible enfin c'est vraiment la
population et il faut aussi dire que on
est obèse mais c'est pas de notre faute
les l'obésité sont si on la soigne pas
bon pour eux aussi en mourir donc ça
c'est deux faits qui sont super
important et puis pour terminer cet
entretien à mon tout de même sur les
actions aussi il y en a à travers toute
la france il y en a dans les yvelines
dès aujourd'hui vous en avez mené et il
y en aura demain aussi ce sera l'hôpital
privé la clinique et de trappes un
hôpital privé de trappes et donc on
initie un groupe de parole à peu près
tous les deux mois justement pour aider
des personnes qui rentrent dans un
parcours de chirurgie à passer le cap
parce que ben c'est pas facile et c'est
un parcours qui est très long et si on
prend pas conscience qu'on doit avoir un
suivi à vie bah c'est loupé quoi
merci à claudine canal est revenu sur ce
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de l'association les poids
plume est aussi vice présidente du
collectif national des associations
d'obèses et on peut nous retrouver dans
différents points
2 du département à port marly à
l'hôpital privé de trappe comme vous
l'avait annoncé à la clinique
saint-louis aussi à poissy et à
l'hôpital poissy saint germain et il ya
votre page facebook
aussi voilà les poids plumes merci à
vous on quitte le domaine de la santé
pour évoquer celui de la politique à
présent dans une semaine nous sommes
appelés aux urnes pour désigner nos élus
rope l'européen nous poursuivons notre
série d'interviews avec les candidats
aujourd'hui mathilde andrew et lé chef
de file du rassemblement national dans
les yvelines 22e sur la liste de jordan
bardet la balise de rassemblement
national est peut-être la seule liste
qui défend clairement et qui a comme
coeur de son action politique la défense
de l'intérêt des français donc à dire
vrai c'est vous voulez vous considérer
qu'un pays doit avoir des frontières de
considérer que les clandestins n'ont pas
être relocalisés dans vos villages que
vous considérez que 80% de la richesse
ne doit pas aller à 1% de la population
et que par exemple l'état peut aider des
entreprises privées à tenir le coup
alors l'état peut aider à rien de
réindustrialiser le pays
clairement il faut choisir leur symbole
national car c'est la seule liste qui
défend justement ce genre de le
localisme le matériel et français avant
toute chose
puis nous prenons une europe des
coopérations
nous défendons l'alliance des nations
européennes il ya bien ce donc qui a en
plus déjà eu les résultats
ariane arianespace par exemple est un
très bon exemple la coopération et ce
qui marche le mieux entre des nations
qui sont libres souveraine libre de
choisir ce qu'elles veulent ou ne
veulent pas pour leur peuple
donc c'est lors après nous défendons ces
deux villes en europe des libertés
chaque pays peut choisir de sa politique
nationale
on peut en effet choisir aussi avec qui
coopérer de manière privilégiée l'europe
est un espace culturel et politique
intéressant qui peut faire face en effet
au reste du monde donc il faut
travailler à cette coopération à cette
réponse face à la mondialisation mais en
même temps ça non plus ça n'occulte pas
le fait que ce qui prévaut toujours
c'est la liberté de chaque peuple
liberté de choisir si le talent ou telle
politique
l'urgence européenne est de rétablir
certaines frontières
la priorité est justement de rock trou
se retrouver entre européens pour
pouvoir construire un avenir européen
en effet cette immersion et des
conséquences économiques graves mais si
culturel et sécuritaire donc il est le
temps à mon avis pour apaiser l'ambiance
qu'il règne en europe de mettre des
frontières à cette europe
et toutes nos interviews des candidates
et candidats sont à revoir en replay sur
notre site internet et applications
mobiles on passe maintenant à
l'essentiel de la semaine
[Musique]
et ce début de semaine marqué à
guyancourt par l'élection d'un nouveau
maire après la démission de main et
christine le tarnec pour raisons de
santé lundi matin les habitants se sont
réveillés avec françois morton au poste
de premier édile sur ce plateau et nous
a expliqué vouloir achever le travail
mené par ses prédécesseurs
ma priorité au moment où nous parlons
nous sommes au mois de mai 2019 les
élections municipales sont en mars 2020
ma priorité en tant que maire est
évidemment de pouvoir terminer un
programme sur lequel pour lequel les
habitants de lui en cours nous ont donné
leur confiance en mars 2014
que répondez vous justement à ce qu'on a
pu entendre de la part de jean-louis
cariat élus d'opposition qui dit que
finalement cette élection votre élection
c'est n'est qu'une passation de pouvoir
entre amis c'est ses propos qu'est ce
que vous lui rim se sont effectivement
ces propos je lui laisse la
responsabilité de total de ses propos si
vous avez bien entendu ce que j'ai pu
dire hier en conseil municipal ce que je
souhaite c'est que le conseil municipal
et je pense que c'est une attente forte
des habitants de la ville de guyancourt
mais dans un contexte plus large et on
l'a vu par le contexte national que les
débats notamment dans ce type d'instance
soit des soit réellement des échanges de
points de vue
pourquoi pas programmatique nous allons
rentrer dans une période de campagne
c'est une évidence pour tout le monde
mais il n'empêche que ça serait bien
qu'on puisse effectivement avoir une
certaine hauteur éducation à présent et
c'est mardi que sciences po saint
germain en laye a lancé une formation
inédite en france en diplôme sur le
renseignement et les nouvelles menaces
le cursus va débuter en octobre il sera
ouvert aux étudiants mais aussi aux
agents déjà en activité reportage
mélanie poker grégory canal
le renseignement un monde plein de
fantasmes alimenté notamment par les
nombreuses séries télévisées sur le
sujet c'est pour ouvrir le secteur vers
les domaines universitaires que science
pause saint germain en laye propose
cette formation le dira m comprenait
diplômes d'établissement sur le
renseignement et les menaces globales a
été développé avec l'académie du
renseignement saint germain en laye
c'est un jeune institut d'études
politiques mais qui en son sein dispose
d'une équipe très engagé sur ces
questions de sécurité de violence de
lutte contre le terrorisme
puisque nous sommes associés à un
laboratoire de recherche qui s'appelle
le cesdip qui est très orienté sur les
questions de sécurité les questions les
questions pénales de façon générale le
diplôme est organisé en 6 sessions de
trois jours consécutifs qui se
dérouleront d'octobre à mars
une formation de 160 heures environ
divisé en trois grands modules un module
sur les menaces contemporaines un module
sur le renseignement et un module sur
les pratiques et les techniques et
chaque module comporte quatre courts
quatre petits cours d'eau avec des cours
sur l'économie du crime organisé un
cours sur le djihadisme salafistes en
cours sur la violence politique et la
radicalisation un cours sur la cyber
menaces ces cours seront donnés par des
professeurs d'université des
professionnels du milieu même diversité
de profils chez les élèves formation
initiale pour les étudiants bac +4
formation en continu pour les agents des
services de renseignement des gens en
poste
c'est une manière pour tout
professionnel d'avoir un éclairage
universitaire bénéficier des derniers
résultats de la recherche
une vingtaine d'étudiants proposera
chaque année la promotion du diplôme les
inscriptions à la formation sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 28 juin prochain le
lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme à
saint quentin en yvelines a accueilli
cette semaine à un groupe d'étudiants
canadiens issus de l'école hôtelière de
montréal au programme visites en
entreprises ou encore visites
culturelles et ils en ont également
appris plus sur les vignobles français
aurélien ondes
quoi de mieux que du vin et du fromage
pour mieux faire connaître le terroir
français à des canadiens dans le cadre
d'un échange une vingtaine d'étudiants
de l'école des métiers de la
restauration et du tourisme de montréal
a été accueilli par leurs homologues
guyancourt toi la france est le pays le
plus visité au monde durant aux
clientèles pour nous au canada donc
c'était c'était c'était quelque chose
un passage obligé sont vus avant d'en
apprendre plus sur les accords vins
fromages le groupe d'étudiants a pu
visiter des grands magasins parisiens ou
encore le château de versailles
l'occasion également de comparer leur
formation dans le domaine du tourisme
je trouve qu'il ya un an des cours de
marketing par exemple que nous on a pas
eu
mais je trouve que on se rejoint sur
beaucoup d'aspects par exemple quand on
fait les tours guidés
c'est assez semblable à ce que nous on a
dû faire on a remarqué quelques
différences entre l'école française et
l'école au canada à prendre on n'a pas
pu se parler de ça mais en fait on a
voulu apprendre à se connaître les
diverses expressions les la culture ce
que c'est vrai que c'est vraiment très
différent
c'est la première fois qu'un partenariat
noué entre le lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt et un établissement canadien
ouvrir nos étudiants à des parcours
internationaux à ce pour l'instant
effectivement ils sont uniquement sur un
parcours européen et je pense
effectivement qu'il ya des opportunités
de travail au niveau du canada et
notamment au niveau du québec l'année
prochaine il est prévu que les étudiants
guyancourt toi partent à leur tour à la
découverte du terroir canadien
économie avec un événement d'envergure
mondiale le salon vive attaque a ouvert
ses portes ce jeudi 16 mai à paris mais
à la veille de ce rendez vous c'est vers
les yvelines que les regards se sont
tournés le cluster paris saclay a
organisé sa journée consacrée aux
innovations et aux start up de son
territoire nicolas landry une solution
de livraison à domicile en l'absence du
client voici la freebox
un frigo stocké à l'extérieur de chez
soi fonctionnant à l'énergie solaire
objectif recevoir ces produits frais
commander sur internet est directement à
son domicile
j'ai commencé les premiers croquis de la
freebox en 2015 et son évolution son
développement les boîtiers électroniques
et l'ensemble de la partie intelligence
artificielle et blocs chaîne d'arriver
progressivement les précommandes sont
déjà disponibles pour une livraison en
juillet 2000 vingt cinq mille fridge box
devraient être produites pour un coût
total de 4 millions d'euros
eric et bill est actuellement en levée
de fonds et cherche de potentiels
partenaires
c'est super activités et pourquoi pas ce
que ça se position sur des secteurs et
sur des domaines qui sont très
d'actualité aujourd'hui à savoir
l'économie circulaire le développement
durable quand je pense que on a besoin
de plus en plus de projets dans ce
domaine à des start up des chercheurs
des grands groupes les acteurs de
l'innovation de paris saclay ont
participé à cette deuxième édition de
spring avec une complémentarité entre
les territoires composant le cluster
vous avez 50 inquiets le pôles
économiques saclay qui est le pôle
plutôt scientifique et versailles qui
est plutôt le pôle culturel donc ces
trois pôles ces trois agglomérations
travailler ensemble pour préparer la
france de demain dans les secteurs les
plus concurrentiels donc voilà pourquoi
on il aujourd'hui la journée de
découverte des innovations s'est
poursuivie à elancourt sur le site
d'airbus
le thème de la visite la cyber sécurité
présentation des enjeux des menaces et
des outils technologiques comme la sib
orange une plateforme d'entraînement
face à des cyber-attaques là va venir
attaquer le serveur qui est tissier et
récupérer tous les utilisateurs qui sont
dans ce serveur est tenté de casser les
mots de passe qui sont un peu faibles
c'est très intéressant pour nous de
rencontrer des partenaires
potentiel divers aussi bien qu'à des
mythes des écoles d'ingénieurs que des
pme des start up et c'est exactement
l'objet de spring qui est en particulier
ici à saint quentin en yvelines et sur
paris saclay où il ya un vrai dynamisme
autour de la cybersécurité et la
digitalisation grâce à la protection de
ses clients et à sa capacité
d'innovation airbus cybersécurité
connaît de bons résultats économiques le
groupe a réalisé une croissance de 30%
de son chiffre d'affaires en 2010 8
l'actualité cette semaine dans les
yvelines c'est également la publication
aux éditions l'archipel de l'ouvragé de
l'ancienne directrice du refuge spa der
murray n'abandonnez jamais c'est son
titre revient notamment sur son
licenciement survenu peu de temps après
le passage du couple présidentiel pour
l'adoption de son chien est nemo céline
ravenet étaient en plateau ce mardi j'ai
voulu raconter mon histoire parce que
j'ai consacré toute ma vie à la
protection animale et en l'occurrence à
ce refuge der murray qui était un refuge
merveilleux dans lequel j'ai passé 19
ans en tant que salariés et 15 ans en
tant que bénévole et j'ai été licencié
injustement en mai 2018
suite effectivement à l'adoption du
chien du président de la république
enfin on a trouvé un prétexte pour me
licencier la direction invoque à
l'époque une faute grave à votre
rencontre celle d'avoir euthanasié des
chiens en dehors des protocoles et aussi
d'avoir falsifié des documents l'espé a
d'ailleurs porté plainte sur ce sujet
comment vous l'avez vécu cet épisode on
a sorti des motions tout à l'heure alors
très mal il faut savoir que j'ai été
auditionné pendant six heures suite à
trois faux contrats de placement pour
lesquels j'ai pu amener les preuves
comme quoi je n'étais pas l'origine de
ces contrats de placement
le jour où j'ai été auditionné il avait
d'ailleurs un document de la spa qui
avait été tronqué
donc oui je les très mal vécu
ça a été pour moi une très très dures
épreuves dans ma vie
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine avec nos confrères
de via grand paris chaîne disponible sur
la tnt en ile de france nous faisons le
point sur l'actualité régionale
aujourd'hui nous nous arrêtons à paris
où la mairie vient de signer une charte
avec les opérateurs de trottinettes
électriques
l'enjeu est double lutte contre le
stationnement anarchique et sécurité des
feux clignotants ou de position qui
s'activent
ce système lumineux pourrait bien
changer la vie des deux roues les plus
vulnérables comme les trottinettes ou
les vélos
c'est cet entrepreneur toulousain qui a
imaginé conçu le dispositif
il se compose d'un boîtier électronique
en forme de télécommande fixé sur le
guidon d'un harnais et d'une lumière
il permet d'indiquer aux usagers les
changements de direction mais pas
seulement
en plus des clignotants vous avez la
possibilité d'allumer un feu de position
donc ça c'est idéal quand on roule la
nuit vous avez aussi le feux
antibrouillards en cas de visibilité
fortement réduite
et aussi la possibilité d'allumer un feu
de détresse
tout ça avec deux boutons l'objet
pourrait bien faire des adeptes
notamment au sein des utilisateurs de
trottinettes électriques
rien qu'à paris plus de quinze mille
engins sont en circulation et les
accidents se multiplient
l'intérêt aussi calorique lights et de
pouvoir garder ses deux mains bien fixe
sur le guidon alors qu'aujourd'hui pour
signaler ces changements de direction il
faut qu'on utilise sa main et quand on
lâche au guidon ça peut être très
dangereux donc là le fait d'avoir ces
deux mains sur le guidon on peut se
signaler
grâce à la télécommande en roulant tout
en sécurité pour le système lumineux
sera disponible dans le courant de l'été
2010 9 pour fermer cet hebdo notre
rubrique ça s'est passé l'actualité à
travers nos archives retour sur
l'inauguration de l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
dont l'un de ses laboratoires le latmos
fait dans quelques jours ses 10 ans
[Musique]
réchauffement climatique hausse de 3%
des émissions de gaz carbonique
diminution de 40% de la couche d'ozone
au pôle nord
autant d'actualité scientifique
alarmantes publiées par les équipes de
l'institut de recherche pierre simon
laplace ipsl dont le siège se situe à
l'eau vs q le nouvel observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif de l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin se développer
dans l'avenir ces recherches que l'on
appelle intégré entre la compréhension
du fonctionnement du système climatique
en particulier
et puis les réponses de la société aux
grands bouleversements globo on est
école interne de l'université c'est à
dire conforme effectivement des
étudiants au niveau master ce qui
concerne les sciences de l'environnement
de l'économie et du territoire et comme
ça on peut former les gens aux métiers
de demain autour du développement
durable
inauguration de ce campus de 30 mille
mètres carrés ce lundi 4 avril soit près
de deux ans après son ouverture mais
latente n'est pas une nouveauté dans ce
projet initié il ya presque vingt ans
finalement la persévérance et les
financements ont réussi à faire sortir
de terre l'observatoire sur un budget
global de près de 32 millions d'euros
70% ont été prises en charge par la
région ile de france
c'est un des lieux
université de recherche que nous avons
le plus financé mais parce que il y
allait au fond d'une crédibilité
française sur la question de
l'observation climatique l'adoption
l'atmosphère la question de la couche
d'ozone et caetera et je crois qu'en
rassemblant il fuit la plupart des
chercheurs pluridisciplinaires sur ce
sujet y compris dans les sciences
sociales
je crois qu'on fait un travail
exemplaire
ce sont vraiment les meilleurs
chercheurs on peut dire de notre
communauté qui sont abrités sous cet
observatoire
c'est grâce aux équipes du latmos du
lsce notamment que nous sommes si bien
positionné aujourd'hui pour pour être
entré dans le classement de shanghai est
c'est aussi des domaines où il ya
énormément de formation prochaine étape
de ce campus universitaire la
construction de logements étudiants et
la création d'une maison de l'étudiant
un lieu de vie consacrée aux activités
des étudiants
[Musique]
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
prochain point sur l'actualité locale en
direct lundi 18h nous parlons notamment
du festival de cannes avec les prés la
présence des yvelinois sur la croisette
réalisateur producteur ou spectateur
excellent week end
[Musique]